four o'clock time for one more rehearsal
in bantam quarter in the capital of
Guinea Bissau
actor Dion China's Kazama directs the
Neto steppin team Portuguese for
bondings grandchildren the group which
has more than 100 members of all ages
promotes the culture of Guinea Bissau
they've already rescued 23 traditional
dances from oblivion the local part of
our work is going to a specific region
where an ethnic group lives and we
collect information about the dance
music and costumes
later in Bissau the group works on the
dance and on the cultural components we
rescued a family since its foundation in
the year 2000 Neto Steven team has won
almost all the local and national
carnival parades gaining popularity
among the youth through traditional
dances and music Nadeau's daemon team
has helped keep children off the streets
and given them an opportunity megali neo
Suarez de Gama grew up without parents
today he is a popular percussionist I
used to lead the life of a street child
I hung around in the streets doing bad
things like stealing
but nato's de bon deemed changed my life
completely now I am studying law at the
University Dorcas Amma's initiative
helps teenagers to discover their own
talents and overcome obstacles in their
lives most of the children in NATO's
Devon team are vendors orphans they
spend almost 70% of their time doing
some work and we support children in
terms of education and health care
quality society and families American
medical mentor
the organization relies solely on shows
to generate income there's no external
support half of the profits go towards
supporting the young dancers such as
Mara Polly no Jew who recently graduated
I used to spend time as a vendor at the
market but NATO step on teams help
enabled me to go to school every day now
I don't go to the Bondi market anymore
I'm too busy at school in NATO Stefan
team also offers literacy training for
parents and vocational courses for the
young currently the group has
partnerships with several schools and
training centres we have 10 to 15 young
people attending training courses NATO
state bond team have already taken
Guinea Bissau as culture to Gambia
Senegal and Portugal and to carnival in
Brazil
you
[Music]